but first the all important Iowa
caucuses they in the books it was a huge
night for Donald Trump take a look I
really think this is time now for
everybody our country to come together
we want to come together uh whether it's
republican or democrat or liberal or
conservative it would be so nice if we
could come together and straighten out
the world and straighten out the
problems and straighten out all of the
death and destruction that we're
witnessing that's practically never been
like this it's just so important and I
want to make that a very big part of our
message we're going to come together
it's going to happen soon too going to
happen soon the 45th president won the
state with a historic 30o margin getting
uh most votes of 98 out of 99 Iowa
counties uh the previous record of a win
was set by Bob Dole in 1988 who won by
just shy of 13 points and as you just
heard during his victory speech Donald
Trump struck what was a unifying tone uh
but apparently according to part-time
make-believe journalists and full-time
left-wing hate Trump conspiracy
theorists like radical Rachel mattow
well Trump speech was too dangerous for
the fragile ears of NBC's loyal viewers
they didn't take any of the speech live
instead no Miss mattow was lecturing
Americans about truth and integrity uh
this is a joke right serious question
does mattow not have any self-awareness
at all no one in the media mob has pedal
more lies more conspiracy theories than
Rachel mattow every night for about five
solid years and it still goes on to this
day uh mattow proudly dawned that tinf
foil hat and spread some of the most
insane craziest conspiracy theories that
we've ever heard now she denied the
legitimacy of the 2016 election an
election denier anyway telling her
viewers that it was hacked by Vladimir
Putin she also suggested that Russia was
in charge of our federal government and
that Donald Trump was a Russian agent
quote the worst case scenario that the
president is a foreign agent suddenly
feels very palpable night after night
mattow and others pushing insane fake
stories about Alpha Bank the dirty
dossier and a million other far-fetched
Russia related conspiracy theories by
the way never apologize never attempted
to correct the record there are multiple
articles dedicated to mattow sent into
the deep end here's one from Politico
titled Rachel maddow's deep delusion and
here's the guardian quote well Rachel
madow face a reckoning over her Trump
Russia coverage well apparently not
because last night she anchored msdn's
coverage of the Republican Iowa caucuses
um journalism that is a joke at this is
NBC News it's a joke of course the same
is true over at fake news CNN for
example here's fake Jake Tapper cutting
off Trump's victory speech in order that
he could cope and see at the same time
take a look we have an invasion of
millions and millions of people that are
coming into our country I can't imagine
why they think that's a good thing
Donald Trump declaring Victory with a
historically strong showing in the Iowa
caucuses if these numbers hold the
biggest victory for a non-incumbent
president in the modern era for this
contest a relatively subdued speech as
these things go so far although here he
is right now under under my voice you
hear him repeating his anti-immigrant
rhetoric anti-immigrant maybe you can
call it pro-legal immigration uh
rhetoric just a thought instead of
playing Trump's full remarks so their
viewers can decide themselves well fake
Jake Tapper decided it was more
important to trash Trump's speech in
real time now let me just let me inform
anybody that may uh accidentally pop on
to fake news CNN Jake tap ER is not a
journalist he's a political hack he's a
democratic operative he's living a lie
uh he just needs to be honest about who
he is Jake it's it's clear you have a
deep-seated left-wing bias and supreme
hatred for all things Donald Trump just
tell the truth about who you are you are
a left-wing radical talk show host
you're not a journalist as you claim and
that's why we very accurately refer to
you as fake Jake of course
self-described journalist like Tapper
and mtow don't just hate Donald Trump
they frankly hate everyone who supports
him take a look Trump has in some ways
become religion for a certain section of
the American electorate and especially
for evangelicals that it's not about the
virtue anymore it's about the vice that
Trump expresses and I think you see that
playing out in Iowa where the
Evangelical vote is key it is Central to
what is going to unfold tonight and it
is very much a group of people that that
mind that Trump is in some ways a second
coming these are white Christians that
this is a state that is over represent
over represented by white Christians
that are going to participate in these
caucuses especially tonight regardless
of whether or not they have any link to
any church it's I am not a Catholic I am
not a Jew and I am right-wing and
willing to get rid of democracy that's
what Evangelical means in real political
ter 80% of the Republican primary voters
agree with this racially charged comment
coming from Donald Trump that immigrants
coming here are illegally quote
poisoning the blood of this country
that's so unsettling you voted for a guy
who said come risk your lives for the
grand wizard come in the snow and the
sleep because I am more important than
your life that's who the 5% voted for
actually was laughing when he said that
here's a simple truth and it's one you
already know the media mob uh they hate
all of you by the way yours truly
included they hate everything about
Americans that don't share their radical
leftist worldview they think that
they're smarter than everyone else well
guess what they're not they don't care
if Joe Biden's policies are hurting
millions of Americans 60% of Americans
now living paycheck to paycheck many
people have to use a credit card for
Bare Necessities they don't care about
what's happening at our border you know
people coming from Iran and Afghanistan
Syria Egypt a you know uh Russia China
they don't seem to care about inflation
homelessness crime or the violence
that's overseas but they are deeply
concerned that Biden's poor performance
and obvious cognitive decline and mental
incompetence uh will lead to a second
Trump term in fact so-called journalists
and Democrats well in the country they
are now in a full-fledged panic mode
former 2020 Biden campaign Aid Simon uh
I'm sorry Simone Sanders uh just ripped
bomic and now begging the campaign to
Let It Go the focus should be on
something else meanwhile former Obama
adviser David aarod not a dumb guy is
once again warning the Democratic party
about a formidable Trump campaign make
no mistake anything can happen between
now and November nobody could predict
with certainty how this is going to end
but Joe Biden has never looked worse
Donald Trump frankly is never look
better and this week a big new
endorsement let's take a
look I'll tell you the people of Iowa
spoke loud and clear last night and I'm
a big believer that we the people create
a government that is accountable to us
not the other way around that we the
people choose who leads this country and
so we heard we the people last night and
that is why last evening I met my friend
here we met in person and I told him
that I would endorse Donald J Trump for
president of the United States hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else